is someone normally sitting there or you
guys left the I'm not gay gap between
you the thing dudes do when they go out
together they leave a seat so you know
I'm not his ass but there's someone
sitting there normally who's that oh
beautiful how long y'all been together
years
okay what's your least favorite thing
about her she not here you know what I
mean we can just be a little secret
between us I don't know how loud that
she don't know who I'm talking to
there's no cameras in that
bathroom
I heard it all hey you passed with
flying colors dude wow I almost got him
in a lot of trouble on accident but now
what a good guy dude in the ring you
just gave yourself a compliment that was
crazy that was a interesting way to
handle it watch this what's your least
favorite thing about him Oh I thought
you were going to say that no
problem that's interesting cuz I've
never seen people married still lying
about like this that's